Gil Frostig.
Thank you so much for
being on 20-minute Leaders.
My pleasure.
So good to have you.
And I'm used to seeing you
once a month on the J-Ventures
at the J-Ventures monthly
meeting where you're also an LP.
So now we have to
do this,
And now we have to do this
online like this.
But actually you're more
than an LP at J-Ventures
Right
you're actually taking a much more of a
Chief Technology role.
Correct?
Yeah, I'm pretty active there.
What does that mean to be a sort
of a chief technology officer
of a fund like J-Ventures?
What does that even mean?
That makes me very proud actually.
I really like the
whole concept of J-Ventures.
It used to be called
J-Angels prior to that.
I think it's a model
of a VC second to none.
There are some things
here which are so unique
and we're going to do great
business on one hand but
lso at the same time,
we're going to build a culture
of the community that is
going to be first of its kind.
A capitalistic Kibbutz.
I've been stealing that sentence
from quite a few people.
Gil, we only have 19 minutes left.
I'm already upset.
So much to cover.
You were at Intel since
graduating from the Technion.
Spent 30 years there.
Climbed the ladder of success
from an entry-level chip designer to a VP.
Moved on onto Qualcomm.
Built products that emerged as number
one in the market of Bluetooth and Wi-Fi.
You're going to explain
to me what that means.
And now you're in Silicon Valley.
One of the most well-respected advisors,
board members, and investors.
Take me back. Technion. You graduate
and you're entering Intel.
What is that like spending
30 years at the company
and climbing up the
ladder of success?
Well first of all,
Intel has been a fantastic company for me.
It is a big company, so actually I got
opportunities here and there. Okay.
It was always under
you know for 30 years,
it was under under the Intel
umbrella, I call it.
But they were very
different things.
So I did start as the
chip design guy in Haifa.
And over time, I moved to the
US and I got a great opportunity
to be a Co-GM of the
business unit there.
And this really opened a
lot of opportunities for me.
And I was I guess very lucky
which is a big part of the story.
What is it like fighting
for those ranks?
Because you know at least you know
young entrepreneurs like myself
all we hear about is, "Yeah, you could join
a company like Intel, IBM, Google, etc.
and then slowly climb the ladder
but that's really hard.
Why don't you go, do a start-up, get acquired
maybe and then just join as a director"
I mean talked to me about
your experience going through what you did
I don't think there's one answer
which fits everyone. Okay.
Michael: Yeah.
Some people are really
born to be in startups.
Okay, this is their personality.
Of course, we know the percentage of
successes of startups.
Somebody wants to try and you
know generate some calculation.
They may but it
doesn't mean anything.
Did you know, did you think you're going
to get to where you got to at Intel?
I get opportunities which were
far better than my dreams.
I can tell you that.
That's incredible.
Yeah and I'm really
grateful for that.
And you know I started
as a young engineer,
there were very good
people around me. Okay.
And this gave me a huge
push through teamwork.
Okay. Which Israel was built on the
shoulders of several you know very good people
who just created the culture.
And we were helping each other.
And it was just a fantastic
stuff for my career.
And then actually, people in Haifa
helped me get to the opportunity I got.
Intel in the US in southern
Oregon in the LAN business. Okay.
And I got to be a Co-GM there which
was phenomenal experience for me.
OGM is?
Sorry?
OGM. What is that?
Co-GM.
Co-GM. Okay. Co-General Manager.
It's the language its called ... in a box.
So, I was mostly
the operations and the
engineering person
and I had a person and I had a partner
who was mostly marketing and sales
and together, we build strategy, and working on the budgets
and leadership
of the organization.
We actually grew in our organization
which was about $250 million
over three years in the late 90s to
become a $1 billion dollar organization.
Wow
And so you know each person can
have opportunities, different places
can excel in different places--
Not that many you know.
You know they say that if you want to
run a billion-dollar business,
you should go be an entrepreneur
because that's really the only way
but no,
you went you know the Intel route
and you still got to manage a
billion-dollar business. Wow.
One of the other fortunes was they
never worked on an x86 processor at Intel.
I always worked on other
businesses which were new to Intel.
So we built a you
know billion-dollar,
this business out of networking
LANs, a LANs solutions.
Then our team,
my partner and I were assigned to build
this new protocol nobody heard of
which was Wi-fi.
Wi-fi. I've heard of that before.
Yeah
But back then
Yeah. People people try to have
wireless solutions for a long time.
But this was the
right time definitely.
So just to get a context,
we are talking about the inception,
the years where the Internet is born
because you know talking to somebody
like me, I don't know what that means.
But there was a period where
the Internet needed to be born
and I get to be speaking now to one of
the pioneers who got it out to the world.
Okay. I'll buy that.
I think the Internet's really
start to spread around in mid- 90s.
And in the late 90's,
we were assigned go and implement this
you know new wireless protocol.
And the folks who worked in
Israel on chips for plans.
They said, "Hey, can you do the same
thing just without the wire?"
And what do Israeli
engineers say?
"Of course we can."
So this was '98 or '99.
And by 2003, we came out with a
solution Wi-Fi into the Intel platform
which was called Centrino.
Again, you need to be half a
dinosaur to remember that name.
It became a real success.
So this was actually together
not only the engineering efforts
but also all the marketing efforts
and the market creation effort.
This was actually the one product and the
one brand which opened up the Wi-Fi market.
And later on, it was so gratifying
to see people who
they just need Wi-Fi as the same as
they need oxygen to some extent.
Okay. It became so pervasive.
You know actually Gil you mentioned
that I was in Kilimanjaro a year ago,
exactly a year ago
with my dad my brother.
We were up on the mountain and we
didn't have Wi-Fi but we had oxygen.
And at some point, I was thinking
what do I want more right now?
And I didn't have my Wi-Fi for a week
and I didn't know what I valued more.
Right right. So this is very rewarding you
know to see how successful this became.
So I was just you know fortunate to be part
of that team which was assigned to start it.
We started something
on the side.
You know for Intel suddenly
they decided to have it as
one of the key components
on the platform.
Wait, that was a side project
it started as a side project?
Yeah. It was something on the
side for this LAN division.
Maybe they can do
something out of it
and then the CEO of Intel realized
that, "You know what?
This could be one of the keystones
here for a new type of platform for Intel"
where we brand not only to the processor but
we brand several elements of the platform -
the processor, the networking, the chips,
the memory. You know things of that nature.
Right
And with all the additional
efforts on the marketing side,
it became you know a big hit.
And this actually opened the
entire Wi-Fi market up here.
What do you learn from that?
So having gone through this experience,
you know I can look at it
in the textbook and see,
"Okay, so this is one of the key innovations
that really transformed people's lives."
You experienced it. so what do you learn about,
what can you teach me about organizations
or about you know innovation,
and entrepreneurship from this example
of this Wi-Fi technology being
born out of these circumstances?
Yeah. So I think there are sometimes cases
were somebody high there starts something
without knowing even if it's
going to be something good or not
and you have to try that.
We also tried DSL and
it didn't go anywhere.
We also tried the cable
modem solutions for the PC
and it didn't go anywhere.
but we tried Wi-Fi, we started
Wi-Fi and at some point in time,
there was a key strategic
decision by the CEO.
So this was, in my opinion, an example where CEO can decide
on some strategy which really makes a difference. Okay.
And because of that, from something on the
side, we just joined the eye of the storm.
Okay. And we had weekly meetings with the
CEO to make sure everything is on track.
With the CEO of Intel?
Yeah.
Wow.
I mean the chipset, and the processor,
and our solution, and everything else.
And you know PC platform is
something pretty complex.
And you don't want to be
the guy who's going to delay
the new rollout
of a new platform.
But it was you know and then
there was also another element
not about the design which
was about enabling the market.
sS the marketing team came and said, "We're
going to build outside places, coffee shops.
You know 400 of them that
will be utilizing Wi-Fi."
So the CEO looked at them and said,
"Why 400? why not 4,000?" Okay.
And this was so meaningful.
and yes, they got the 4,000
and it really went
terrifically from there.
And other companies also
grew up in that area.
Some of them thank Intel 'till today
because they became rich too.
Wow.
Gil: yeah, it was
That's incredible.
And what does that mean
building the platform
that at the end gets number one market
share in Bluetooth and Wi-Fi technologies?
Well, this comes to you know your
work as a team and as a P&L
So the trick in big
companies like Intel,
they put people
in business units.
People have a lot of affinity
to their own businesses
and they wanted to succeed
in the marketplace.
I'll tell you the story actually about
our Gigabit Ethernet controller.
Okay. LAN controller which
we built around the same time
and we competed head to head with Broadcom.
It was huge battle. Okay.
And it was just about the
question of who can do faster,
who can do develop it
faster and high quality.
At the end of it, I remember till today
Dell was the king of the hill in PC's at that time
and we wanted really bad to
win Dell and so did Broadcom.
And the design win changed places at Dell
between Intel and Broadcom five times.
Last and fifth time was Intel.
Okay. This was one of the
best days of my career. Okay.
Especially when you take into account
the guy who ran Broadcom at the time,
Henry Nicholas and his
eccentric behavior.
You can write about it,
you can read about it in the media,
in the gossip columns,
wherever you want to see it.
But it was a huge, huge win.
Wow. That's just incredible.
and Gil, you transition from this then to,
you transition from that to
Silicon Valley helping companies,
helping both early and late
stage companies succeed
both at GigCapital where
you're a strategic advisor
but also as part of J-Ventures.
So why is that? Because you go from
these huge, huge corporations. 30 years.
VP at intel.
VP at Qualcomm and all of a sudden,
you're working with startups.
Yeah, so I've been in the
Valley here for 20 years.
I still work here for Intel
quite a bit and for Qualcomm.
But since the day I got here,
I actually started to get involved with startups.
I still found the time.
get engaged with startups.
Usually, they came through
my personal network, friends.
okay, people from me Israel
or something like that.
and because I missed that.
I really wanted to learn more about that
and help where I keep where I could.
And I found some great startups
and great people to work with.
And over time,
I also learned to trade by doing so.
At some point in time, I decided,
this is about two three years ago,
I decided, "Okay, corporate America
was great for me. I'm thankful
And I want to do everything around
startups going forward." Okay.
And I just you know I left.
I went to pitch events, pitch nights
between San Jose and San Francisco
every day in different place
just to meet more people.
see more startups, see what I learn,
see which one I can
actually help.
You know I started to be an advisor.
Many of them
an investor in several of them
And then I had you know,
then I found Oded Hermoni
and J-Angels as it were
called at the time.
And this is you know a
bunch of great people.
Some of them are VC's in the day job.
Some of them are
CEO's who were successful in
driving their companies' exits.
Corporate people.
So it's a great mix.
And right now, I feel more comfortable
investing through or with J-Ventures
because I think we're really doing a
good job here on due diligence side
as well as on the connection side.
You know we're having 60 members right now.
And people are very connected.
And we can not only be investing
and making money out of it
but to actually help the
startups that we invest in
through the connections.
we have people in the Valley
and we have people
around the world as well.
So this became a very,
very quality expense for me.
I am mostly,
most of the my time is about startups.
I met two new startups
today, earlier. Okay.
And it's it's wonderful.
Michael: I love it.
Nominal ideas. Okay. you see great
people and you can help them.
What could be better? Tell me.
A 100 percent no.
But Gil, are you still
in the you know hardcore
networking scene
or are you now branching
out to other things as well?
I did branch out a lot.
Networking is one field.
If I can help there, it's great.
But over the last 20 years,
I really learned a lot of things
which are you know relevant
to many many types of startups.
Could be Fintech. Could be biotech.
Medtech. Okay. Really lots of areas.
Now if I don't have anything smart to
tell them, I don't tell them anything
but there's some experience
which you know plays by now
and I can help
really a lot of guys.
So you know give me some of those
earned secrets over the years
both as you know corporate America
but also as a start-up advisor
and a strategic investor.
What are some the most important
things to keep in mind especially now
considering the times
that we're at now?
And let's say for
early-stage startups,
what is it the common thing that you
see come up both that at J-Ventures
but in other startups that you
see that some phenomenas?
Yeah. So there has to be
some good differentiation.
Now differentiation could be in the technology
or could be in the marketing of it or wherever.
But if you don't come with
something which is really new
and gain you lot of momentum
relative to the competition,
it's going to be very tough.
It's going to be
very, very tough.
People who are open to feedback. Okay.
Sometimes they need to pivot.
They come with the pivot
the startups. And you know what?
It's a great idea. I mean not having
your people every three weeks.
But you know you listen to the market. You
listen to customers. Listen to other people.
You still have you know the initial
strength that's you and your team
that you can say,
"Hey, you know what?
It could be more applicable here
and I have also some connections
or this investor given more
connections in that area"
Okay. So if they keep
flexibility, it helps a lot.
Right. And I mean you know a lot
of the startups that we're seeing at J-ventures,
a lot of them are early stage
and you can always assume that
throughout the lifetime of this company,
which hopefully will end in success,
there's going to be
quite a few pivots.
So a big part of also the due diligence is understanding
who are the founders behind this great execution up to now
and are they flexible
to pivot when necessary?
Let's say like in
times of COVID-19.
Yes and the founders have to be very
also open to learning new things
because if they are first time CEO or first
time CTO, they have to understand that it is a script
and how it evolves over time.
You know things like
a lot of presentations.
So I see a lot of companies
on their presentation
or you know before
angels or VC's.
They tend to talk a lot
about the technology.
They tend give a big, big background of how the
world is changing, what are the new trends
while these things could be known
already or too deep technically.
And you have to be a businessman.
Okay.
You have to understand that the financials
that you do here, you plan here,
should be very,
very clear and substantiate it. Okay.
And the entire story
of how you raise funds
and all the ins and outs that people
really care when they're investors.
Okay, your personal
story could be nice,
but don't spend time on it.
Don't spend time on it.
These are businesspeople
who sit in front of you.
They want to see how you,
they're going to make 10X on your startup.
It's not cynical. It's a very good, it's
a very good test. Okay. For you as well.
And you have to understand
the rules and get into this
you know very, very quickly.
Otherwise, you're going to be in love in some
of your slides which are not that relevantm
and you're going to
waste people's time.
And then, you will not going to have enough
time to explain the important things.
So after two years of J- Ventures, after
seeing 200 startups in the last three years,
I actually wrote my own lists of slides
and what the investor care about.
And I sit with CEOs and help them
understand what they need to present,
how do you need to present it.
Don't need to rush.
Speaking too quickly. Okay.
There's a lot to learn. and you get
one shot. You get one shot. That's it.
It has to be perfect.
Sometimes people tend to wing it and think
that "It's okay, my invention is so smart.
everybody will get it."
The answer is no,
they will not get it
unless you really,
really simplify it and explain it slowly.
I love it. Gil, I love it.
I love it. I love it.
But we have to we have to finish, I can't believe
it's 20 minutes already.
I have the most important
question for you.
Three words that you would
best describe yourself as
or as anybody at J-Ventures would
describe Gil Frostig as.
Okay.
So I would say first of
all, grateful. Okay.
Okay. Finally.
First of all grateful.
I think I've had a
hundred episodes.
I don't remember grateful
as being a word yet.
Okay.
The other one is I love people.
And I enjoy working with them.
Okay.
It's just you know
just a dream for me.
And the other thing is try to be as thorough
as possible in this environment. Okay.
Definitely. Definitely
Gil, such a pleasure.
And thank you for all everything that
you're teaching me at J-Ventures and here.
And then I look forward to maintaining this
relationship and learning more from you.
Thank you very much.
Gil: All right.
Thank you. Thank you for the stage here.